College snowflakes are melting down at
universities across the country
assaulting professors and vandalizing
buildings Antonio Okafor is here to tell
us why we should let them have guns then
though Rachel and Paul Bois joined the
panel of deplorable z-- to discuss
democrat senator dianne feinstein's
anti-catholic religious test Hilary's
wonderfully destructive book tour
Trump's daca deal with Pelosi and the
alleged to a sexuality of women's
nipples
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show I am joined today by
campus carry activist Antonio Okafor and
really Antonia needs no introduction but
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
her work I just wanted to play a quick
clip of Antonia every day of her life
that is a striking resemblance to John
Rambo a striking resemblance you look
much better in person thank you I have
not been working out as much as I used
to you're much less of an Italian man
than you so you are the leading campus
carry activist in the country probably
oh well what that's what I would say I'm
not flattering I think that's true
what is the 30-second pitch to let
students at college campuses carry guns
oh yeah well okay first of all I do not
think that the people there see
snowflake worthy of that name should
probably have a gun but more likely
they're against guns so it's okay and
that barrel would just melt them so it's
really a moot point oh really what they
don't want people to have to but
basically it's the fact that those
people who already have a concealed
carry license off-campus that they
should have that same right on campus
that's really what campus carry is about
it's not also it's not about making
these superheroes or ever oh you have a
good a permit and you have a gun and
therefore you now you're able to protect
everybody on campus and kids something
happens it's about really Liberty it's
about personal protection about making
sure that I have that right to
self-preservation that the Second
Amendment guarantees really under God
we're really not really by the
government so it's a natural law yeah
yeah and even more so those people who
dis hate the Constitution if you just
bring into the whole self-defense aspect
of it it's like you know you talk about
sexual assault on campus well why don't
you allow these women to be able to
protect themselves on campus and and
that's what the whole campus carry
issues about because women are not as
physically strong as men that's just a
biological thing okay I know I know I'm
triggering the whole audience here but
they aren't and then there's this great
equalizer this sweet sweet justice that
just sends freedom seeds down the firing
range when you became a campus carry
activist you you were not a gun nut you
at you were you just shot a few times
right what made you pick this issue yeah
and that's why I bring the whole Liberty
aspect of it into is because it really
was not a oh yeah I love guns and I just
want everyone to have done I mean now a
two years in I do
but you know where it started you know
it started because selfishly you know I
was a woman of college campus on my
college campus I was a graduate student
and I was walking home at night and I
realized that I had no means of
self-protection of protecting myself
that you know it's not okay for me to
just have you know 9-1-1 in one hand
with my cell phone and that's Lou they
would do it have nine one one and have
it pre dialed and my finger on the the
submit button and then I have you know
the rape whistle that they give you in
freshman year orientation saying here
you go hope you don't get raped I mean
that that's basic but I hope someone
hears the efforts so that's basically
what it came down to you and I realize
you know I don't want that for women and
to be an empowered woman I think it's
really about you know protecting
yourself before something happens not
talking about health care insurance that
you know deals with something that has
already happened that's right and the
whole thing there is this insane idea
that you're going you have a rape
whistle and you're gonna blow the
whistle and then the rapist is gonna say
okay all right well I didn't know you
had a whistle I'll see you later when
you're screaming alrighty I'll come back
when the cops come and then he can
arrest me right yeah and the cops even
that that's the whole issue that people
talk about from the left right I heard
about this New York Times op-ed about
that and most of this in New York Times
audience was saying that most of the
responses like well you just get it you
know a police officer when the week
before they're like we hate cops I'm
like you guys gotta choose one way or
the other
but really it's this they might come in
six to seven minutes but a lot can
happen in six to seven minutes and so
why don't we going to refrain from
making any jokes about that because I
think they'd be in poor taste but you
make a very valid I employed one that
was truly that is that is it's both a
joke and a reality yeah you know
everything that matters in that scenario
is gonna happen before the cops get
there nine times out of ten and you
wrote there was a great New York Times
piece and you wrote in it this is a
personal thing for you you grew up
within a single-mother household you you
had been assaulted you this is this
isn't just some political philosophy
conversation this is something that you
can really speak about as
as an individual absolutely and also the
fact that at that point when I was
making those decisions of man I do want
to fight for this issue because you know
it is not even a political issue because
I dealt with it but I was coming from
the left at that point I was brand new I
I think I only think at that time I made
a decision that I realized you know what
I do have conservative values and that's
why I realize I can strongly you know go
to the point that it is not a political
issue it really is me American issue
this is a human rights issue it really
is but particularly with women and the
differences that science has proven over
and over again but really when it's not
even just about that I mean you're you I
mean you are coming against someone who
is a male or woman who has a firearm
that person is gonna win you know
regardless of how big you are your male
or not no I am very much so it is true I
physically intimidate a lot of attackers
at least one of those is true but now
even despite all those great qualities
you know it's it's still bad for you at
that point to have something that's
gonna be an equalizer so I think that's
important do you think there's a racial
component of this too you know
specifically toward arming young black
women who are say disproportionately
more likely to be assaulted or do you
think there is a racial inequality on
this issue I think I mean this that's
I've been showing that black women and
the white women are the fastest-growing
demographic who are becoming gun owners
and so I think they are seeing that
whether it's a political issue and
that's a lot of people they they hate
the fact that you know black women are
now becoming gun owners and so they
twist it well it's because the less what
happened to last year oh is Trump ain't
no racism and it's the spinning is this
bidding you know it does blown up the
record and that's why our gun now yeah
to protect against Trump Trump in the
racism that's you know just prevalent
now it isn't kind of it
no and I always said they talked to me
about that they'll interview me about
that and be like no it's been happening
the last few years before we even knew
about Trump so I'm gonna do with that
for me I think it's also has to do with
the rise of women in general you know a
lot more about you talk um and a lot
more
are you know by a by yourself at home a
lot of us are still pursuing education
longer and maybe you know that
transition from leaving a household
where your father figure is there and
then having it where your spouse is
there is that there's a bigger gap there
so a lot more women feel that they have
to take safety into their own hands and
I actually also think that's just an
extension of you know if you want to
bring with them in this aspect of it the
feminist movement is an extension of
that independence and so black women
especially are in these areas that tend
to be you know since is statistically
more dangerous and they're by themselves
and so I hear all the time with other
women with their daughters and like I
want to buy his gun cuz I wanna protect
my daughter I want to know how to use it
I want to protect myself so I think
that's really what it's about that's the
single woman aspect of it is so
interesting because it's if a woman is
living with her father living with her
husband or partner whatever live-in
boyfriend there is a physically
hopefully somewhat strong man there to
give her back up but if she's living
alone or living with young kids there is
a very thin line between her in danger
absolutely yeah absolutely and really
doesn't have to be about race I was on
my American news network and I was
debating this Democratic strategist and
he was like well women don't need guns
because I mean you guys need an advocate
for health care but our health care
insurance and rise and pay the right to
little boys and right some abortion of
course even though the woman is not
gonna be live another point but okay
right important and then also you know
that you have better you know it manages
in though in the workforce I'm like how
does that even or a better access to
education like okay even I have all
those things I have great health care
I really do I haven't one of them I have
great health care and I'm college
educated and grad school and I still
need a gun to protect myself
listen attacker I make an extra twenty
four cents on the dollar without
controlling for education so back off
absolutely absolutely I am I'm empowered
through
through health care benefits know all
those things are after the fact that you
still need a firearm or whatever doesn't
happy a firearm and that's what's like
we've empowered the organization that I
started it's not just having a firearm
that's gonna be there for protection
because first of all you know you could
be younger than 21 just not gonna be
able to do how much that permit I mean
there's pepper spray it's having a knife
or whatever whatever means you can use
table to protect yourself but a lot of
universities are even keeping like
pepper spray from being an option
Massachusetts does not allow anybody to
have pepper spray on our club other than
Tifa when they pass through borders
exactly exactly then they're oh they're
totally okay I mean they're so they're
so thin I mean they need something but
everybody else everybody else is our
white supremacist know you so from what
I can tell your politics are slightly to
the right of Attila the Hun or Genghis
Khan it was not always that way you
voted for Barack Obama twice yeah what
happened I know it was really cool too
there's so many people that I know I'm
like wow you vote for Obama but yeah
particular of my age um but yeah the
second time is when people were like wow
I don't know if I can trust you but I
think it was really the economic issue
it was the fiscal side of realizing that
first of all Obamacare and how egregious
that was the economy absolutely in the
backs of my generation and you know
saying public policy at the time who
knew like actual facts could change
someone so but yeah basically that and
then realizing also that you know all
these policies even if you just focus on
African Americans if you really are just
focused on that because that's right
when the reason why you know as a black
woman as a white person a lot of us
voted for Obama because we were just
like well this is our chance to do
better first black president
historically yeah absolutely and they
believe all the hope and change that you
talked about and then realizing that and
not only did they not help the black
community if you're just looking at
their poverty rates were high or welfare
you know being dependent on the
was hired like having food stamps as a
staple your your legacy if that have
more food stamps than you have before
it's not it's not something I want to
aspire to encounter my babies yeah
exactly and so this looking at that
issue really made me realize that I
wanted to change over at leaf on the
economic side and then everything
Liberty really just changes everything
else and the gun issue really helps you
so you felt the social issues followed
from the economic issues I think so yeah
a lot of it but also I mean you talk
about this you know coming for an
Italian you know background and you know
my family is very conservative and does
values right even though they vote for
Hillary and Bernie last time they I know
a lot of people in minority communities
they really have these conservative
values but because they see reality yeah
it's not there isn't latte-sipping on
the yacht there isn't you don't go to Al
Gore's movie premiere I'm sorry that's
I'm just like okay with Bernie and like
okay that's nice but my momma is not
talking about like by the way there are
more polar bears today than there have
ever been in history even on that ad
drives me crazy but you're right who
nobody is saying ah but in a hundred
years the temperature might be point two
centigrade higher and so let's listen
screaming kids oh I can't calm down we
need to talk about the polar bear even
more so they're like unless you're
talking about that's for me to eat yeah
I don't really care but I do care that
you know I think I can't go to this
other party or another party because
they the media tells me that they're all
racists and they're sexist misogynist
and that's what I think really gets them
unfortunately is regards to the value
system and that's the same thing I had
to is that but media tells me that their
racism a hate me as a person so there's
that social aspect that virtue signaling
yeah absolutely I recent you know I
recently had dinner with a friend of
mine friend of mine for 20 years we went
to middle school together high school we
sit down she said do you really believe
the things you put on Facebook said I
don't even know what I put on Facebook
but presumably I do she said what is
your racist now what we're many black
girl friends posters on my wall
sweet little Missy so so this is a
person I've known for 20 years but
there's this heavy virtue signaling sick
oppressive culture surrounding
conservative politics how do we break
that well the ironic thing about that
too is that when you hear what these
people on those left are saying if
that's the real racism right there with
the policies like oh you can never oh
one of these professors I got in trouble
one of those elitist ones that you know
trouble because they basically said that
there you might have heard about it it
basically said that having the best way
to have a better life is kind of this
middle class you know culture and middle
class behavior and you're getting
married and you know having kids you
know in bed walk and stuff like that and
people got mad because they said that
she they were racist because a pod
person could never do that no black just
looking at like there's no one see how
racist that is there is no definition
those guys in Richard Spencer there is
no difference they are two sides of the
same coin I absolutely agree but then
I'm gonna be called a racist that's
right I say stuff like that so I am now
white supremacist I don't know last
night you saw me yeah I am that's
actually that's a bit I always suspected
of you an attorney about alright let's
bring on some of those other
supremacists there at least deplorable
we have to introduce our panel we have
zou Rachel His Eminence Paul Bois and
we're gonna keep Antonio Gafoor around
for the panel so let's get right into
the news in the name of tolerance
democrats are instituting religious
tests against prospective judicial
nominees here is dianne feinstein
grilling an appeal court nominee
Amy Barrett
when you read your speeches the
conclusion one draws is that the dogma
lives loudly within you and that's of
concern when you come to big issues that
large numbers of people have fought for
for years in this country was that even
English I don't even know if what she
just said was English Dianne must have
forgotten article 6 of the Constitution
which reads quote no religious test
shall ever be required as a
qualification to any office or public
trust under the United States other
Democrats are doing it too she is not
alone here dick durbin a senator dick
durbin asked Barrett if she considers
herself a quote Orthodox Catholic Bernie
Sanders grilled the Office of Management
and Budget nominee on whether he thought
Jews would go to heaven so we have to
ask Bob wha do Jews go to heaven no I'm
kidding I'm gonna ask you a different
question the dogma lives loudly within
you your eminence what is up with the
resurgence in anti-catholicism from the
government well we're definitely a long
way from the days of people putting no
Catholics allowed in their storefronts
I think we've definitely evolved into a
full-blown anti-christian sentiment but
I think the main reason why Pelosi I
mean Feinstein and Durbin are
specifically targeting her for
Catholicism is because a faithful
Catholic well which is what she is and
someone like Scalia is are gonna operate
under the dictates of Thomas Aquinas
which states that a government has to
bow down to the laws of God so that
means that that's going to inform their
legalistic decision-making which means
no same-sex marriage no abortion and no
socialism so pretty much everything they
stand for goes out the window I must say
every single thing that Paul was says
sounds about as authoritative as it
could possibly be and for those of you
who are not watching you really ought to
watch because it appears that Paul's
coming to us from directly in front of
the Vatican so a great joy I didn't know
you were travelling Paul but that's X
so is there any legitimate concern that
someone's religious views could make
them unfit to hold office in the United
States well is this Darth feinstein
dogma flo strongly through you you know
if you have in our constitution you have
the right to life and it can't be
deprived of you without due process of
law and and and and the rights that uh
that fall underneath that here's the
thing you can't adhere to any of those
rights without some basis of faith now
when we say due process of law what law
we talking about because you you can't
say that these are inherently
qualifiable rights by man because
another man will have a different
perspective on those laws that's why you
have lynch mobs lynch mobs that will go
and say no this person is guilty no
trial by tear we're gonna Lynch him
right here without processed so you
can't say that these are inherent
qualified laws you have to apply faith
to know that there is a law that says
you cannot deprive a person of their
life their litter due process without
without this law and once again
according to what law there has to be
the faith that puts this on a foundation
of a particular law that is beyond the
qualifications of man that's also sure
the so heads-up I say in short you can't
help but apply faith to this law and it
has to be a particular faith that
squares with this law that is such a
good point and nobody makes it everybody
talks past it but you're right there is
a a meadow law there is a faith to even
believe in the law and people say all
the time they say well we can't
legislate morality but all we do is
legislate morality tax law is
legislating morality health care
provisions are legislating morality we
bring our views of the world and human
nature and government to bear when we
construct laws for our society and
everybody this is that right right and
once again what morality though they're
still with it still comes down
eight of which morality is the most
sound and most conducive that upholds
our inherent rights that can only be not
about our feet and that brings up
another question about this which is
Antonia something tells me that a Muslim
nominee would not have been grilled in
this way by the esteemed senator
Feinstein is this religious test being
applied selectively oh yeah absolutely
and that we see that with a lot of
things too even with the feminist right
they'll they'll attack all the
Christians they'll say oh my gosh you
know you're bringing back women decades
and everything like that but they will
never talk about Muslim people oh and
Islam which is very I would say probably
very anti feminists as if like they
scream understatement of the year
okay seriously like they get to choose
pick and choose who they want to say is
gonna be a part of the cause like you
know Linda Sarsour I mean of course I
mean she's the one who talked about a
jihad and stuff like that and then also
what is one of the three Allah when she
said that she actually wants you know
about to be pardoned the law of the of
the US although the land and then the
feminist article you know suddenly quiet
about that I mean that's that's that's
what we're basically dealing with where
there's no actual principle here there's
no you know logic or reason it's just a
pression higher arc AB solutely well we
can move on to another esteemed
religious Reverend Reverend Hillary
Clinton Politico is reporting that
Hillary campaign alumni are dreading her
forthcoming book tour with anonymous
staffers reacting quote oh god quote I
can't handle it and quote the final
torture now to date Hillary has blamed
her election loss on the FBI James Comey
the Russians Vladimir Putin anti
American forces low information voters
the optimism of her supporters pollsters
Barack Obama's re-election Barack Obama
himself voters desire for change
misogyny suburban women the mainstream
media television executives cable news
Netflix misguided documentarians
Facebook Twitter WikiLeaks fake news
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden and
Cydonia that's kind of hard to figure
out Antonia
what does Hillary hope to accomplish by
blaming everybody else under the Sun is
this about her legacy is this about
protecting her family's reputation what
is she doing well the ironic thing
though is that if it's about protecting
her family's reputation or herself it's
not say making it worse I think it's
like any reasonable person is it's like
okay I mean this is a little bad you're
not happy you know like the fan or
whatever her name is you know the one
the redhead was you know basically
coming back two days after that whole
Trump thing I just whatever do you know
actress or whatever it just own up to it
it was your fault and you have more
respect male or female when you do that
but she's not deciding to do that and I
think it's soon it's going gonna hurt
her cause and whatever her cause was
cause of making $100,000 yeah whatever
that I think the Clintons were the cause
and this brings up the loyalty questions
oh the Democratic Party has been pretty
good to the Clintons they have supported
them for a long time why is Hillary
Clinton going on a 15 City attack the
Democrats tour isn't it a little
ungrateful good some good words man look
I have the best words don't you know you
get good work good work
okay if that's just Democrats this in
their nature to throw people under the
bus that's just what they do and in
terms of uh you know in Hillary's gonna
try to get you know she's gonna throw
that and try to terminate them the same
way she got rid of him emails and got
rid of that server and you know when
Democrats they have they have to
separate themselves or somehow sanctify
themselves in their own sanctimonious
way or why it is that they're the losers
that there are it's just like you know
uh you know she said is that owned up to
it
own up to what it is that you did now
like I said even with you when you got
these drones out there trying to remove
like these uh these uh Confederate
symbols figures in history
the flag and stuff like that they're
trying to separate themselves for what
is their fault and Dale Hillary Clinton
is following that model she's trying to
separate herself
search every search so well what is her
fault in turn depending on somebody else
so Rachel typically pulling his punches
typically very calm and no you're
absolutely right so it's exactly it it's
just passing the buck and running away
the moment that there's trouble paul
paul bois the longer that hillary
clinton remains the face of the
democratic party the better it is for us
it's absolutely terrific president
Trump's approval ratings are fairly low
but I know if one person whose approval
ratings are lower
that would be Hillary Rodham Clinton
according to an NBC poll that just came
out her approval ratings are thirty
percent the lowest that they have ever
been
who are the Democrats going to put up to
counteract the attacks of hildog well I
think it's pretty much the case now
Democrats are Trump's greatest ally and
as they've gone knee-deep in this
intersectionality narrative they ran it
for eight years with Barack Obama they
tried it with Hillary Clinton it did not
work out and I think they're just so
wedded to it they're gonna have no
choice but to run the intersectionality
narrative again and the only person that
they really have that kind of fits that
bill is Kamala Harris so Elizabeth
Elizabeth Warren is not gonna yeah
Lizabeth Warren is not gonna do become
all Harris is probably the one of
they're gonna run and as long as she's
tweeting out tweets about how Trump
can't pardon people who've been
convicted of a crime then I don't think
we have anything to worry about here but
loose war and I I thought was a Native
American which as far as I can tell is a
Morris minority than Kamala Harris
Antonio did you say well yeah I just
think it's funny cuz it's like oh well a
black person Obama and then Hillary
Clinton is a woman just put them
together very good that's how we
actually went next time it's not has
nothing to do with actually Jesus's
continued up with the first of
everything a black woman first president
you know
it's gonna get really weird like five or
six candidates down the line when you
start mashing different things together
two heads coming out who knows President
Trump tweeted out this morning for all
of those daca that are concerned about
your status during the six-month period
you have nothing to worry about
no action in that trumpian exclamatory
way here is Nancy Pelosi gloating about
it some of the concerns that people have
when come out is came out of it but I
said six months and these people are
being fearful that it said pack up
because you're out of here in six months
not we have six months and we're gonna
pass it there so take comfort so that's
why I said to me I might Hugh calls this
morning I said thanks for calling this
is what we need that people really need
a reassurance from from you mr.
president that the six-month period is
not a period of round up what is just
that the the daca is frozen and that
these people will not be vulnerable that
is really hard to watch and after that I
can't believe I would leave you on this
but I have to say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube I know you're begging you said
why didn't you cut it off before Nancy
Pelosi came on so right now if you're a
subscriber we appreciate it
you help us keep the lights on and bring
out great people like Antonia and
Marshall gets to keep this job this week
so go over to daily wire.com right now
it's ten bucks a month 100 dollars a
year you get me you get the intro flavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show forget
all that doesn't really matter you get
the leftist tears tumblr this it is
obviously waterproof salt proof snow
flaky proof it is the finest vessel for
delicious liberal tears you can have
them hot or cold always salty always
really really delicious so go over there
right now daily wire calm and we'll be
right back
[Music]
Antonia President Trump seems to be
buddy-buddies with Nancy Pelosi today is
this the long dreaded long waited Trump
pivot to the left no it really is the
tweet it it's from fini
and you're just like god this is one of
those like oh so Congress so it's up to
Congress really is what it's really
about but it's no it's good you make a
great observation which is it's just a
tweet every time we go crazy mr. ripping
our hair I always say this is the end of
the Republican Party it's just some
tweet and then it moves on and you tweet
something else and it's not a big deal
it doesn't destroy the country well I
hope your optimism is proven correct
Bob wah this is a tricky situation what
is the best path forward for president
Trump regarding these so-called dreamers
certainly is a tricky situation Marvel
it's one night certainly struggle with
as a Catholic and I certainly do have
compassion for the dreamers and the kind
of situation that they're in however I
do believe that daca is not the way to
solve it especially with Obama just
ramming it down our throats through
executive order so what Congress needs
to figure out here is how can we
compassionately deal with the dreamers
who are here under no fault of their own
while simultaneously giving a strong
deference to the law here and that's a
that's a difficult tightrope to watch to
walk so they're gonna have a tough time
doing it but I'm still up in the air
about how to handle it I'll tell you
with that answer I wish you were on the
u.s. Council of Catholic Bishops because
they may be making all of these awful
political statements that seem to me not
quite infallible though the everybody
thinks that these dreamers are a bunch
of eight-year-old kids but the dreamers
our result is 36 years old
it is not they're not all four-year-olds
some of them are well into their
adulthood what would have been
considered until recently middle age why
are Democrats so much better than
Republicans at coming up with these
emotionally manipulative euphemisms
man that is a good question and I pray
that we get an answer but you know at
the same time I think we're asking these
questions of you know of Trump in the
House and the Senate and me and these
other people the question I'm asking is
look if America is this rotten country
of these awful people why is it that
y'all think that you can come here and
improve your lives why is it that you
think that you can be a better person of
coming to a country of awful rotten
races people so you had a moment it
these new unionism is nightmares that's
what they are they're having is there
obviously dream with this literally
future in this racist wasteland all
these things that you America
why don't you yell at your government to
give it to you fabulous country under
this you know this youth this College we
got free health care and everything's
supposed to be free education and free
housing on that sort of stuff
how's that working out for you so well
when you have to come here and impose it
on us to give it to you yeah let your
government yelling at us wake up from
that dream come back to reality a new
law this is this is much happier news
than daca this is I really want n to
show on a positive note a new law
Mabry the nipple in Berkeley California
progressive councilman Chris Worthington
explained quote if a woman's nipples are
fit to be seen by the most innocent and
impressionable portion of the population
I thought he was talking about me but it
isn't as babies and toddlers then it
stands to reason that nipples are not
inherently sexual and are fit to be seen
by the rest of the population if that
woman so chooses man if that's progress
sign me up you certainly do not ask me
how I feel tutorial at the end of this
segment
though our nipples inherently sexual
[Laughter]
but liberals then I wouldn't find
anything sexual about it Bolivia this is
before puberty when a kid is like a
young this young toddlers when they see
these things as food they haven't like
gotten the hormones to start to process
them is anything different so now that
here's you know and biologically listen
yes they are inherently sexual because
they're there they're sexually specific
you know when you have these attributes
that actually define a woman defines her
sex then that actually makes them sexual
that is by definition sexual thank you
why do you spend money on this stuff I
always tell sweet little Lisa that my
back hair is very sexy and she disagrees
but I'm gonna bring no Rachel's argument
to her Paul
Bob wha if men can show their nipples
but women cannot show their nipples then
what do we do about transgender people
if a man thinks he's a woman or is
pretending to be a woman or dresses like
a woman can he show his nipples this
seems to expose a great issue that the
Berkeley City Council is finally solving
whoa
mind blown on that one like a man that
identifies as a woman can he show his
nipple Wow I mean I'm stumped there yeah
few thousand years of Catholic theology
will not answer oh no no no resurrect
Thomas Aquinas for that one I'm lost I
mean I think if we're on the subject of
defining terms I mean do we even have to
call them nipples anymore I mean can we
just call them like the little pointy
brown things on your chest I don't know
the little pointy round things on their
chest always words of wisdom this is our
show we do have to end this on you I
won't request the practical tutorial
promised at the top but is this evidence
that feminism was really invented by a
man a very clever man who decided that
he would get easy sex and get to look at
nipples all day and not have to work
that hard or pay for dinner and is this
sort of feminism what we all mean by
empowerment oh man you gotta put in
there so I
currently reading The Feminine Mystique
so I guess I'm gonna figure out what
that means afterward after I read this
book I'm still 70 pages in so we'll see
how that goes but um yeah all I know is
that if you want to know what real
empowerment is go to empower to a organ
you can find out this we're gonna find
ok panel thank you so much it's always
good to have you especially Antonia but
also so Rachel in His Eminence Paul Bois
now it's time to go back to guns for the
final thought the debates over gun
control and the Second Amendment give
off like the freedom seed spewing boom
sticks they center around lots of loud
noise and hot air here's the argument
for the Second Amendment it protects the
freedom of people from tyranny there are
endless statistics demonstrating the
public hazards and benefits of gun
ownership a homeowner protects his
family a woman protects herself against
an assailant a trained gun owner
prevents a mass shooting or terrorist
attack by killing the criminal before he
can kill the innocent people around him
but the essential defense of the
individual right to keep and bear arms
that Americans have cherished since 1789
is that it puts the government's money
where its mouth is and offers a blunt
defense against those hypothetical but
perfectly plausible oppressors who would
pervert the meaning of laws and language
to enslave us without the right to keep
and bear arms the people are ultimately
powerless the Second Amendment is the
constitutional provision that protects
all of the others that's our whole show
today
come back tomorrow we get your mailbag
questions in we're gonna be answering
all of the life-changing questions I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
[Music]